hello everybody I hope that you are good
I think it's time to make this video
it's a broader market update especially
focused on the alcoy market and it's an
scenario that I have on my mind that I
want to share with you uh just so you
are prepared for it in case it does
happen again we don't know if it'll
happen or not but it's worth being
prepared for it because if it does
happen I believe it'll be a great
opportunity perhaps the last one to get
into into alss before uh they they have
a good leg up okay or as is going to be
my case it's not I'm already 12 but if
this opportunity comes I'll use it
basically to get into my final spot
positions okay to add size to my already
um current backs now we're want to start
with Bitcoin then we'll go through the
Bitcoin dominance chart then we're going
to go through ethereum and I've chosen
11 altcoins some of them and is because
you requested them yesterday on my post
on on X so yeah I got a few Al there
more than 10 so it's possibly going to
be a longer video than usual Bo that's
not problem just get a drink and and
bear with me so let's go with Bitcoin
Bitcoin in the higher time frame we've
already analyzed this move when it when
it when it before it happened even and
basically we're seeing here the
potential breakout retest of the trend
line we saw that
this breakout was going to happen
because again this came to the 50% level
to the mid level of this of this channel
so that was to me the the sign that it
was going to be a breakout here okay
because again when you're in a channel
breakouts don't happen from the bottom
of the channel they usually come if you
notice to the 50% to the mid-range then
they come here break out retest
sometimes you get it sometimes you don't
but we were hoping for it and then
continuation to the upside so yeah very
happy to get that move also the retest
we didn't try any shorts during this L
up so H that's where many people make
mistakes because they were thinking that
okay this is going to be some kind of
fake out and PR on to reverse back down
and continueing this channel for some
more months and those liquidations uh is
what fueled the move top okay then when
we were here around these levels 90 we
saw this train line we're want to go
into the 4 hours time frame now and we
saw the uh potential of
this uh trading setup that so far has
been playing out over the next past few
weeks and it could continue still do so
I'm going to go through the validations
but first the reason why I was
supporting this this plan was because
the move seemed very very extended look
at this okay pay attention to the 4our
50a the 4our 50a usually it get tested
frequently you can see it okay usually
does and when you see a overextension
from the 4our 50 m like this that
usually is calling for a for a pullback
into it okay now because we were very
close to 100K I was thinking that
pullback and most of course
before we hit 100K because it's a very
psychological level very strong
psychological level the same as for
example if you go into the
S&P they're going to see the same okay
look what happened at 6K at 6K price
doomed okay and it went it I think it
dropped how much was it 3% okay that for
thep to be honest is quite a lot so it
doesn't usually break above a
psychological level
in the first attempt you usually take
two three attempts so perhaps now the
S&P can break above it if it manages to
hold support here around 6K then yes it
can continue going up high okay same for
Bitcoin so if you go back to
bitcoin then the same applies it was not
likely that I that it broke P 100K in
the first attempt perhaps it'll take a
few more attempts Okay so something like
this then yes it can continue going
higher but in the first attempt it
usually doesn't happen especially when
it's s around psychological number like
100K also because the move was so
aggressive there were many new Traders
that's why you can see for example the
coinbase app escalating into the rank of
most downloaded apps in the Apple store
or in Play store and that's because many
new people were coming into crypto in
this area here and they were buying
Bitcoin they were buying Al coins
ethereum Solana and they were going to
take profits in Bitcoin exactly 100K
that's why it didn't get hit because the
market maker is not going to hit those
take profits right it hit exactly
99588 that's how this game works okay
and that's what you need to be ahead of
what the market maker is really going to
do or that's that's the end go in my
opinion
now this structure here is a bullish or
is a bearish okay so in a high time
frame
perspective this is not bearish at all
okay this is this is in fact looking
pretty good for continuation go again
into the weekly time frame why is this
Bish not at all okay you can see price
going up no problem I don't see any Bri
structure the only thing that concerns
me is in low time frame because in lower
time you can see that right now we are
below the 4our 50a you can see it's been
test it's been testing as resistance for
quite a few days and that could signal
that's possible that a new Lo down
happens okay now of course the
validation is going to be in my opinion
to get
back above this trend line here because
that means that this would be a
deviation okay so the first thing is to
get back above this train line here
that's the first sign and then if we can
actually sustain above
98k that is telling me we're going to go
to at least
105k that would be my validation okay
but so far what I see is that the most
likely
scenario is that we continue going lower
either from the 4 or 50 m or from
testing again this trend line around 96k
and then continue going lower
I have two levels where price could find
some support and in my opinion those
would be
88k but
88,500
okay you can see
there this was the first resistance then
it became support a few times so that's
an important level also there are a few
liquidations around that level and the
other one is to take the lows around
85,000 personally I don't see much lower
than Bitcoin could go to I think you'll
find at least um I think in the worst
case scenario and possibly what it's
more likely to happen is that Bitcoin
comes to the lows s the lows get back
above them find support and continue
trending higher and here is where the
opportunities come and I've been saying
these guys since were here I was saying
price is likely going to go to around
96k mid90s 96k especially that's what
I'm going to take a short okay and this
pullback here is where the money is made
because if we can get to Al coins during
this pullback there is going to be great
opportunities especially let's go to the
Bitcoin
dominance but perhaps I'm going I'm
going too fast I hope that you guys are
following but there a lot of talk so
let's get into it now the Bitcoin
dominance for the last few months we be
marking the same level 61 to 5% okay
we're saying around 61 62% then I came
with this level you can see how that
level has been perfectly hit okay and I
don't think that it's likely that we go
to 52% 50% and the drop
here not sure if it be an old
because on All Season also depends on
bitcoin I'll tell you what all season is
All Season happens when the Bitcoin
dominance goes down while Bitcoin goes
up then alons are going to pump really
hard and that's an old season however if
the Bitcoin dominance goes down but
Bitcoin
ranges okay alins are still going to go
up but that's not cold season cuz it's
not the same you don't want to see Al
doing 50% each day right maybe you see
them doing 15% 20% but he not as strong
as the past all seasons we've seen
however I do think that I'm not sure if
it's going to much with Bitcoin going up
or with Bitcoin
ranging but um in either way I do think
that is very likely that Bitcoin
dominance goes down and that Bitcoin
doesn't drop okay so I'm supporting the
theory the alins are going to be doing
really well for the next one to two
months okay uh that's in my opinion
where the opportunity is come and I'm
telling you this when I've never been
beish on the Bitcoin dominance I've
never called for an old season before
this you guys know it that's why I love
Twitter CU everything is written down
with dates and you can see my past
tweets so yeah I've never called for an
old season before in fact I when when
there were some influencers scoring for
All Seasons here or here
I was telling you guys don't listen to
it Bitcoin dominance is looking bullish
because first of all it's breaking from
this range then is testing it a support
and it's going to continue going up it's
going to fill out all these imbalances
here okay that right now are filed so
yeah I don't think that Bitcoin
dominance has have very good chances to
start retracing from this level from
that reaction perhaps it comes back up
and drop in my opinion right now that
seems a be difficult perhaps he goes
again to 59 60% and that's when you can
see starting to go down sharply okay but
in either
way um altcoins in my opinion are going
to have a very good Rune over the next
few weeks again one to two months very
likely so that in my opinion this is
where the opportunities come now if
Bitcoin let's go back to bitcoin really
quickly just for a second if Bitcoin is
going to continue retracing okay either
from the 4 or 50 May or from this trend
and resistance if it's going to go if
it's going to continue
retracing okay and make new lows in this
very low time frame Trend even POS
possibly taking even the lows here that
is going to make altcoins give you some
very good entries and we're going to go
right now through them I hope that this
part was easy to understand for you that
you are all following because it's the
most important part is the context if
you don't have the context then you
don't know what's going to happen so um
well in fact we don't know what's going
to happen but we can use the context to
make some plans and to be prepared for
them right so uh that was the first
thing I wanted to mention then if we
check the ethereum versus Bitcoin chart
and we go into the weekly time frame you
can see that right now we're having a
pretty good reaction from here my left
it's 0.03
018 we haven't H it yet Perhaps we don't
it's around 5% lower again perhaps we
don't and prices start to go from here
well prices I mean ethereum versus
Bitcoin it start to go from here okay
then possibly recovering all these
levels but what I mean is that if we
actually continues going down I do think
that there'll be a very good reaction
from this level and I'm not expecting it
to go any lower than that okay so yeah
that's basically telling you that
ethereum is going to start outperforming
Bitcoin soon if it's already not going
to going to do it from now right and
from then the cyle goes Bitcoin does
well then ethereum out performs Bitcoin
ethereum starts to to to do well versus
Bitcoin and then Al coins follow right
and that's where we going have an season
so everything is setting up nicely for
the ALCO Market to go up also and I'm
not much of a believer of the seasonal
Trends or the monthly uh Trends but it's
true that ethereum usually does pretty
well after Thanksgiving there are
usually some good Ries after
Thanksgiving day and that's around the
corner so who knows maybe maybe it's
actually a real thing and it continues
with that Trend now if we go into
ethereum and US
pair let's have a look we want to start
now uh talking about the potential pull
backs and buying opportunities that I'm
paying attention to which I think that
they are going to be quite shallow
rather than deep and this is my ethereum
chart here and I do think that this
level here is going to hold at that's
3,000 for several reasons I have three
reasons and I explain this on on X but
I'm going to go through this again on on
on on video the first thing is that it's
a psychological level 3,000 that means
that there is going to be a lot of buy
limit orders set there that could push
price up the second thing is that we
have the daily 50 May which usually it's
a very good uh Trend indicator you can
see here that for a downtrend he starts
here when we lose the daily 50ma and we
are testing our resistance then again
there okay then we overcome it so we're
going to have psychological level daily
50a and also a support that is already
established you can see there so I think
that this level here is going to hold
now I'm not sure if price will give us
this buying opportunity especially
because the ethereum versus Bitcoin pair
is doing fantastic right now so it's
possible that we make that we don't come
all the way here but we actually do a
higher low okay perhaps somewhere around
3,150 something like that right that's
what I'm trying to
get I think that if we get any pullback
or any deep in ethereum wish should
would uh again Financial advice but is
it's recommended based on the context to
get into those dips because ethereum is
going to start our performing Bitcoin
very soon so if we are bullish on
bitcoin on high time frame perspective
and we think that ethereum is going to
soon start to outperform bitcoin of
course you want to get into ethereum
right so any deeps in
ethereums is for buying those are buying
opportunities right so yes maybe
somewhere around 3,150 if we are very
lucky then around
3,50 but those are the areas I'm looking
at if again if Bitcoin drops to 88k or
85k and potentially from there of course
we're going to go into into the highs
okay 4,000 another psychological level
and from there we're want to see the
reaction but perhaps you have something
like this okay some consolidation and
continue going high I don't know we'll
see near the time next altcoin Solana
I'm going to first go through the ones
that I covered yesterday on on X very
quickly these ones Solana
very one of my favorite Al coins it
makes a lot of money on fees so um it's
a project that can continue evolving
improving themselves and of course
reaching more people more projects in
the ecosystem and the prices should
continue going high okay so yes if we
get something like this that'll be
perfect because if you notice here you
would be aligning at deviation below the
previous high and also a suppor TST from
the daily 50 mate that I like so much
you can see here guys support support
then prices do L Ops okay so if that
happens again what's going to happen
another L off from that all right so
yeah that's the level there if we can
get somewhere between 2 210 and 205
perfect that's what I'm looking at okay
next one uh
Dodge dos have been the most uh cheeky
because I don't think that this is going
to get triggered or I do think that this
one is the least likely to get triggered
but if it does I'm buying and that's why
I like to share these setups because if
they actually happen then you've been
prepared maybe you can leave some limit
some buy limit orders there and if we
are looky then we're going to be very
happy and
Dogecoin um what do I have to say
elections do coin in the you have L mask
there H this is going to go high this is
going to go really high and again going
to the Daily time frame is
extremely
overextended but it's DOD and DOD at
this time I don't think it's going to
give you a deeper pullback than this all
right if we actually do which again I'm
not sure if we will I'm being quite
optimistic here to be honest um
optimistic in the way that I that I'm
going to be lucky but again it be it
wouldn't be a
surprise because I'm going to leave some
by limit orders here but I'm not
expecting it okay I'm only hoping for
this so that's Dogecoin then also
yesterday we talk about
Tia so let's have a look this is a
project that I've been in since
basically this area here
and although I've done a few buys I
remember I did a buy here at the daily
50 ma then we came low another buy there
so at the end my average entry is
4781 I think it is
so PR much is at times two from here but
I'm not setting yet okay I think that we
are or at least should go to to 12 you
can
see in time frame that this is some kind
of range to consolidate and to load up
for the for the next leg up now we're
above the range highs we're
consolidating there no signals that
we're going to get back into the range
so to me this seems a consolidation
above support before the next leg up so
yeah I'm not selling any single token
yet I'm being quite H greedy with this
one because I think it has the potential
to go to uh 11
87 okay that's what I'm selling and
possibly at least I'm I'm taking up
there 75% of all my Holdings all right
although again yeah it's possibly that
it goes to to 20 but that's what I'm
taking most of my of
my profits there another one that I
talked yesterday on X
Wasa this one is quite strong um not
sure
if we'll get it um I remember that I
enter here at
034 but I took profits too early I took
my profits at
049 I think it was so around here in
this area here quite early then continue
rally and I want to get back in it with
the with a good size so I'm hoping that
we get a pull back H but I don't think
we're going to get a pull back lower
than this okay in fact this is too high
you should a little more like this uh so
if we narrow the
area if we are again very
lucky somewhere around 049
050 that would be great but for that we
need Bitcoin to continue dropping okay
um again if if this happens I'll be very
happy because I've been trying to get
into this uh into good size again with
this token for a few
weeks now EXC I'm going to use my phone
cuz I have in notes a few Al that you
guys have been mentioning in yesterday's
post so I see say so you guys have been
tagging me a lot with this Alco here I
think I've charted in the past perhaps
even in YouTube I'm not sure but I have
here has some
drawings and what I see here is that we
had some kind of a range then the
breakout then a deviation below the
range then it goes up a small small pull
back goes up and it looks quite strong
to be honest okay this looks quite
strong and I see an efficiency here I
see a liquidity pull there and that's
exactly a 105 so we should in theory
expect to
reach this level here okay 105 that's
the level I will be expecting it to
reach at least and if I look for
potential buy entries
I see it quite difficult because it
looks quite strong it feels like this
would be an Aline
that we should have got there area below
040 and just held for a long time
because to entry to enter here seems
quite difficult perhaps if we are
looking we can get another entty at the
450 M cuz if you notice it's been tested
quite frequently but it goes up quite
steadily
so let me check this
to me this
looks like a small I repeat a small
range something like this let's go into
the 1 hour time
frame okay and now if we change the
liquidity P the 50 Ma and we'll put the
one in the four of time
frame all right
perhaps it's
possible we could first see a deviation
here okay about of the range
Highs but it does seem that price should
come again to the range lows perhaps
even a a sweep of the lows that
deviation there and that's what I would
look to enter okay so around
0.60 and 0 59 I think that's the area
that I would like to enter okay um if we
get that it's not much of a pullback I
think it's a 10% only when I'm thinking
more of a 15 20% into some mcoins by to
that this one is strong so if you want
to DCA in cuz you are not already in or
you you took profits to too early and
you want to jump back in like it
happened to me with Ena then I thing
that 060 059 should be a good first
place to enter and then if you are looky
and I repeat if you are very looky then
perhaps you can look for somewhere
around here okay
somewhere
around this area here this box between Z
54 and 052 as a second entry but that
one is perhaps stretching it too much I
don't think we'll get there personally
but yeah those are the two levels that
um I have for you guys okay more theum
this is one of the projects that I like
the
most you guys know that um what is is my
chart of the
lium that one there so far it looks like
a very
tight support and resistance range here
and I'm expecting to some Point Break
above this this resistance here test it
a support instead of resistance and then
continue going higher okay and yeah for
this one I do think that has the
potential to break Above This level and
go to to plus $1 that's what I'm
thinking that'll happen in the next uh
all season and for this one I'm not
holding anything well I'm not buying
anything in a spot and all I've done was
to buy some notes that they generate
some daily uh tokens they generate me I
think it's 17 to five tokens each note
per day and I don't have to log in or
anything they just do it
automatically so that's the way that I'm
um getting exposure to to this project
and I remember that I bought the notes
in March this year I remember I made a
video about it or I mention it in a
video so far I've already paid for half
of the of all those notes I have at this
moment more than I think it's 16 notes
in total so the goal is that eventually
price goes up and I can get all my money
back from those notes and then I can
ruin them as long as the project leaves
for cuz those notes don't have an expire
date and I can get all those uh free
tokens which is passive income over the
next few years okay that's that's my
that's what my idea with the thisum so
yeah hoping that the project does well
so yeah I do think that eventually we
want to break this resistance and
trending higher okay and this looks very
similar to this other token that is
called ta well to or Theo I don't know
how you say it but also artificial
intelligence same as the Le and it looks
very similar cuz you can see that is
quite a tight range here of support
resistance I remember that in the last
uh well I've got two two spot entries
one was here at 415 I think it was
415 and the other one was a 485 so those
are my two entries that I have on this
token and again I do think I eventually
will break Above This resistance here
okay tested it as support which we
couldn't do in the previous uh two times
tested it as support and then continue
going high into 850 and 100 at least
okay so um then that's probably when I'm
taking profits you to go a very nice
week there right so look in fact if we
get the 50% of
this that is taking us to 4 to 880 okay
pretty much what I said so that's what
I'm going to take most of my profits in
880 um so those two tokens there I have
more for you I've got four more I got
sui let's have a quick look at
this okay in the last video I mention
sui and to be
honest we nailed it because we were
talking about when we were at 2.10 we
were talking about a 25% correction in
the ALCO market and it happened exactly
to level 160
uh based on history based on what
happened here previously okay happened
the same thing there so uh yeah I have a
good history trading this Alin here um I
hope that it can continue be that way so
let me try to chart this s strong at the
moment
but look in 4our time frame I see
something very clear already and is this
lows I don't think that is very likely
that we come back to this lows okay
perhaps another deviation here super of
the lows and then price to continue
going higher so somewhere between 285
and
275 that would be my
area to buy H Su okay or to long it
that'll be that'll be the area my
opinion if we get that how much of a
drop is this
15% yes around 15
177% it it matches with my with my idea
on bitcoin Okay so
yeah that's the chart there for you guys
pretty fast the next one is
arbitrium
arbit let me have a
look okay these two levels are outdated
so let me get rid of
them okay the first thing that I see
here if you go into the weekly time
frame it'll be EAS to
see it's very interesting
that the top was an M
pattern and the bottom was a w
pattern quite symmetrical the way this
uh Aline trades to be honest in fact you
can see better in the daily time frame
I've just noticed now what do actually
what does usually happen with M patterns
and with W patterns so if you look guys
here with the m pattern
you develop them pattern you drop you
have a retrace you continue dropping
okay now it happens the same with the w
patterns W view forms lack up retrace
continuation okay this is the ret that
I'm looking for now if you want to the
four well let's go again into the time
frame I see a potential pivot
here this area here
081 let's go down to the four hours time
frame and let's remove
this matches with the 4 50 May that I
see which it has been consistently
tested and then we see L Ops from there
so perhaps we get
again there
okay
and in the worst case that that level
doesn't
hold then we have here another potential
support that is right here okay
so what if what even here if you want to
be safer
so this one seems quite quite deep to be
honest that would be quite deep pullback
and I'm not expecting the pullbacks okay
so that one I don't like it I think I
like more this one somewhere between
z81 and
079 if we are looking we get this okay
so around there that is the area that I
would like to see our B trading into if
Bitcoin drops low okay then from that
area we can continue going
higher somewhere like this okay uh no
much of a of a pullback quite shallow
must be around
10% yeah it's around
11% I don't see arbit going much lower
than that if I I'm being honest with you
so if we get it then well that's a good
buy opportunity now chain
link chaining used to be one of my
favorite alquin of all times in the past
I remember and to be honest it trades
very nicely and we've go very good H
moves on this one and I have a good
history trading trading in this C in
spot I remember I made a video that
before this happened saying that we want
to see a deviation below this range but
that would be a great buying opportunity
in a spot we got it 520 then what
happened to me is that I I remember that
I sold half of my position here at the
range SI and the other half of the
position was
here so in this area here all right by
the way this is very similar to what is
happened to H Tia if you notice Tia is
right now in this precise moment here
and now we have to go towards this level
towards that P but anyway that's the way
that I got out of in and out of
Link then in the last um Al market
update that I made and I was talking
about the possibility that the Bitcoin
dominance was quite strong and that the
Alin were going to have a a big drop we
were talking about these three buying
areas all of them got hit look at the
last buying area the lowest one
you got exactly tacked there very very
close to it but you got hit and right
now I'm on link um
however I want to take profits quite
soon on link because I prefer to get
into other projects I'm going be bor of
this project to be honest now the idea
where I'll be potentially taking out
75% of all my of all my Holdings
it'll be around
30 somewhere around there because I
don't think that that'll be a Quest from
resistance from the from a psychological
point of of view so if we get there then
I'm getting out of
chaining
um quite heavily and if we get a
pullback
guys if we get a pullback
it's quite difficult to be
honest let me
see 4 50
May should take this low in
principle you should take this lows in
principle if we see a pull
back give me a little second what
happens in the daily yeah take this
lows take those loads and possibly trade
into this level here
possibly trade back into mid 15s
okay
so yeah if we get a
pullback let me readapt
this yeah if we get a pullback I do
believe that I would like to see those
lows taken
out and then this other level here to
hold so that do that this box between
16.16 and
15.5 that's the area where I would like
to see chaining trading into and holding
for continuation to the upside to 30
right that's what I think for chain link
and I only have one last Al that you
guys requested I was
phantom phantom is another
another Alum that trades very nicely
on R
here okay um you already can see what it
is is is the current Trend higher lows
and higher highs very clear Trend
expecting a higher high in the higher
time frame therefore we want to get into
into Longs okay any pullback that we get
we want to get into because we're
expecting a higher high all right now
what can we enter let's go to the forest
time frame
but it seems pretty clear to me
already it seems pretty clear to me
let's go into the one time frame
now
okay it seems pretty clear to me that if
we can
see our
retrace back to
z94 which I believe that match with four
or 50 MAA so if we can get a retrace
back here and it holds like this then
that'll be a good trigger to continue
going higher into that higher high all
right so I don't know how much of a
pullback is this I think it's around
10% yes 10%
pullback um potentially could be even
even deeper but that's at least the
level or the trigger that I would like
to get into for Phantom I don't see any
other clear triggers right so 094 it is
10% drop from here if we get over the
next seven days or so uh that'll be
great in my opinion that'll be a very
good entry um but for that of course we
need to see the 4 or 50 Ma and this
support holding quite strong so yeah
guys again I'm not saying that this is
what is going to happen in the ALCO
Market okay is just an scenario that I'm
keeping on my mind for in case it
happens but if you guys know to this if
you guys notice the total
three it's looking very good okay this
is a total three this is the total
market cap excluding Bitcoin and
ethereum okay so this is pretty much
stable coins and altcoins and here you
have mem coins you have Solana you have
also us you have Stables mem coins alins
High caps mid caps low caps pretty much
the overall Alin market so it's a
looking like it's favoring the upside
also if you again align that with the
potential Bitcoin dominance
drop that we are potentially going to
see and also with idea that
Bitcoin should
hold yeah let me the time frame is fine
should hold in the potential scenario
that we see a deeper pullback also going
have the daily 50a to support us so in
theory Bitcoin is only going to pull
back to continue going higher right so
based on all of
this we we should be in ANS and I think
I don't think that the video should be
useful in terms of being prepared for a
potential pullback to get ready for a
buying opportunity that perhaps it might
be the last one all right so um I hope I
can guide you well on on on this one on
this take so thank you so much for
watching again make your own decisions
do your own research and thank you so
much for watching see you soon